le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
afin de palier au chômage chez les
jeunes à la réunion
le département a mis en place le cnar
mme comité national d'accueil des
réunionnais en mobilité
ce dispositif met en relation les
demandeurs d'emploi à la réunion avec
des recruteurs en métropole et à
l'étranger pour soutenir les jeunes dans
leurs démarches
cette interface comprend un
accompagnement personnalisé pour chaque
étape de leur parcours au travers des
portraits croisés de jeunes réunionnais
qui ont sauté le pas tiffany et didier
reviennent sur leurs expériences de
mobilité
[Musique]
je suis dauphin de la place dauphine et
la place vente a mauvaise mine alors par
d'autres vérifient bien le fond durée
yeux s'éteindrait stoppa c'est pour
c'est pas les ruptures les ruptures du
matin petite révision matinale pour
tiffany arrivé depuis 4 mois à paris la
jeune réunionnaise est en train
d'apprendre le métier alors la grande
distribution j'ai fait des stages dans
la grande distribution que j'ai beaucoup
aimé j'avais fait je m'en souviens quand
j'étais au lycée j'avais faire un stage
à score express
c'était à dix minutes de chez moi je
faisais de la mise en rayon il y avait
une bonne ambiance j'ai beaucoup aimé
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé d'en faire
mon métier c'est plutôt une question de
passion je dirais
malgré un diplôme en management des
unités commerciales la jeune femme est
passé par des périodes de chômage
avant de partir là ça a été vraiment
très dur pour moi ces derniers ont pas
été facile les échecs les entretiens qui
n'ont pas abouti et à après c'est une
ancienne prof à moi de mon lycée lycée
professionnel de vue-belle qui m'a
transmise l'offre de monoprix
je me suis dit j'y avais plus rien à
perdre pourquoi pas faire l'entretien
d'embauché
deux semaines plus tard mon téléphone
sonne lui disant que j'étais enrichir
monoprix un mois plus tard je réussis ma
première embauche que j'ai signé que
j'ai envoyé toutes les pièces dans les
temps grâce aucune arme
tiffany a pu être accompagnée depuis son
départ jusqu'à son hébergement
alors avec le cnam gvt unifiée du billet
d'avion et de logement pendant deux mois
donc il faut ça au début qu'on arrive
dans l'apathie tellement d'argent donc
être financée au logement au niveau 2
mois c'est franchement c'est un
soulagement pas et après c'est vrai
qu'on a quelques petits versements sur
le début qui nous soulage pas mal j'ai
pris ma fonction
deux semaines après mon arrivée donc ces
aides ont été vraiment très utile pour
moi mais comme je lui ai dit c'est
vraiment une expérience à ne pas rater
dans la vie
quelques arrondissements plus loin au
palais du luxembourg
[Musique]
suite à un stage à la capitale qui la
réconfortait dans son choix de carrière
didier n'avait qu'une idée en tête
retourner à paris
alors actuellement je suis au restaurant
du sénat dans le palais du luxembourg
j'ai de ma promotion autres qu'adjoint
mettre de tels justement grâce à mon
ancien employeur de l'amharique m'a
proposé de d'avoir ce poste là au sénat
pour l'aider dans ses démarches
didier a pu bénéficier de l'aide d'une
arme alors l'aide du cnam qui m'ont aidé
pour mon billet d'avion
donc une fois installé ici à paris il
est mon berger pendant trois matches une
famille d'accueil chaîne d'ancré
lyonnaise pour justement m'aider dans
mes démarches
professionnel est pour et pour me
trouver pour me trouver un logement
après ces trois mois ce que tout seul
tout seul venir à paris et quitter lille
c'est vraiment pas évident pour un jeune
qui débarque comme ça du jour au
lendemain et c'est grâce aux bonnes âmes
et à leur accompagnement justement que
je peux revenir sur paris pour le jeune
homme avoir pu traverser ces épreuves
avec succès est une fierté
ah oui mais les filles ammann est fier
que de quitter mon île de venir
travailler ici sur paris et puis c'est
pas facile c'est pas évident et puis
c'est quelque chose qui me tenait
vraiment le coeur c'était vraiment un
rêve pour moi de venir ici soit pas
envie de m'installer et puis j'ai galéré
j'ai galéré au tout début quitté la
réunion du jour au lendemain par les
blessures pavie s'adapter au climat
s'adapter au style de vie et donc malgré
ça j'ai pu quand même la motivation
et puis j'ai essayé de persévérer dans
mon domaine même si quitté la réunion
peut être une expérience douloureuse
le succès est souvent au rendez vous
même s'il connaît pas sa part parce
qu'ils étaient sonnés les venir en
métropole ce n'est pas évident il y à du
travail en métropole beaucoup de métiers
sont en tension et les entreprises
recherchent
des travailleurs réunionnais et sont
très satisfait notre est-il de leur
comportement et de leur manière de
travailler si évidemment hélas il ya
parfois des échecs et des gens qui ne
regrette d'être venus très
majoritairement c'est une réussite et je
viens en métropole assez régulièrement
je tiens rencontrer des candidats que se
sont intégrés dans des entreprises et je
vois des jeunes épanouis proposant aux
réunionnais d emploi en métropole et à
l'étranger blick marne est une interface
entre les demandeurs d'emploi et les
employeurs pour bénéficier de cette aide
il faut avoir plus de 18 ans et être
demandeur d'emploi pour accompagner au
mieux les réunionnais le cnar l'on peut
prendre en charge le billet d'avion
il propose également une aide à
l'hébergement une prime à l'installation
ainsi que des indemnités pendant la
durée des contrats en alternance pour
plus d'informations rendez vous sur le
site du cna remet au www.caf.fr
[Musique]